Vamos a hacer un montón de ejemplos y muchos
de estos ejemplos tienen que ver con crear
una ecuación con los datos que nos dan, para
así poder resolver este problema.
Y bueno, con esto vamos a resolver el primer
problema, que nos dice, escribe una ecuación
matemática que describa la relación entre
las variables de la tabla.
Y si te de das cuenta, aquí tenemos del día
y la ganancia por día, en el primer día
ganamos 20, en el segundo día ganamos 40,
en el tercero 60, en el cuarto 80
y en el quinto 100. Y bueno, si te das cuenta,
la ganancia va aumentando de 20 en 20, 20, 40, 60, 80, es decir que por cada día que pase,
vamos a aumentar 20 nuestra ganancia,
más 20 nuestra ganancia.
Y por lo tanto, si nosotros queremos escribir
una ecuación matemática que tenga que ver
con la ganancia y el día, voy a poder decir
que la ganancia es igual a 20 por el día...
a 20 por el día...
Y date cuenta que eso es totalmente cierto,
si por ejemplo estamos en el día 5, vamos
a ganar 5 por 20 lo cual es 100,
entonces parece ser que esta fórmula funciona bastante
bien, es una expresión matemática pero si
nosotros lo quisiéramos tener mucho más matematizado podríamos decir que la ganancia es "g"...
La ganancia es "g", el día es "d" y entonces,
la ganancia es igual a 20 por "d", "g" es
igual a 20 por "d" y entonces ya tenemos aquí
una ecuación matemática que nos describe
lo que está sucediendo en la tabla,
el inciso b nos pregunta,
¿Cuál es la ganancia en el día 10?
Entonces lo que hay que hacer es sustituir
el día por 10, porque estamos en el día 10.
Entonces la ganancia en el día 10,
¿Quién va a ser?
Pues bueno, ganancia es igual a 20 por el día, pero estamos en el día 10,
entonces voy a poner en lugar de día, 10
y 20 por 10 es 200,
por lo tanto, en el día 10 vamos
a tener una ganancia de 200.
Muy bien, ahora el problema 3.
Y dice, escribe una ecuación matemática
para los siguientes casos y resuelve.
Así que vamos a hacer el inciso a, dice...
Siete veces un número es 35.
¿Cuál es ese número?
Y bueno, cuando yo hablo de un número, puedo
hablar de cualquier variable, puede ser "x",
"y", "b", "a", sin embargo para hacerlo mucho más
habitual y para tomarnos la variable más común,
voy a pensar en "x", cada vez que yo vea un número voy a pensar en "x" y aquí dice que,
siete veces "x", siete veces un número es,
recuerda que "es" es el signo de igual, es 35.
¿Cuál es ese número?
Y bueno ya tenemos esta ecuación o esta
representación matemática y aquí hay dos formas de resolverlo, la primera, puede ser dividiendo todo entre 7,
si yo divido ambas partes entre 7, voy a obtener el resultado de "x", así que dividiendo entre 7,
estos dos se van a ir, 7 y 7 se van, esto pensando en el lado izquierdo de la ecuación,
mientras que del otro lado me queda, 35 entre
7, por lo tanto, la respuesta de esto va a
ser "x" igual a 35 entre 7, lo cual es 5.
Bueno, esta es una forma de resolver este problema,
porque también podríamos pensar en la siguiente forma de resolver el mismo problema,
multiplicando esta ecuación en
ambas partes por 1/7, es decir, me quedaría
1/7 por "7x" es igual a 35 por 1/7, pero de
aquí llegaríamos justo a lo mismo, porque
1/7 por "7x" me quedaría solamente "x", mientras
que del otro lado me va a quedar
35 entre 7, lo cual es 5.
Así que vamos a hacer mejor el inciso b.
Dice, un número es 25 veces más que dos
veces otro número y aquí ya estoy metiendo
dos números distintos, así que vamos a ponerles
nombre, voy a decir que "x" es un número
y "y" es el otro número...
"x" es un número, "y" va a ser el otro número...
y entonces, ya con esta nueva anotación,
vamos a tratar de escribir esta ecuación,
dice, Un número, es decir "x", es, entonces
pongo el signo de igual,
25 veces más...
25 veces más, entonces 25 más...
que dos veces otro número, por lo tanto voy
a poner dos veces el otro número, pero el
otro número se llamaba "y".
"x" es igual a 25 más 2 veces "y",
esto es lo que me dice la primera ecuación.
Y por otra parte me dice, si cada uno de esos números
se multiplica por 5, su suma es 350,
esto quiere decir que si multiplico a cada
uno de estos números por 5, es decir, "5x"
más "5y" porque me voy a tomar su suma,
su suma debe de ser 350, entonces esto tiene
que ser igual a 350.
Vamos a escribirlo con matemáticas.
5 veces un número más 5 veces el otro número,
"5x" más "5y" esto va a ser igual a 350,
que es lo que me tiene que dar la suma de estos dos.
Encuentra los números, es decir, lo que necesito es el valor de "x" y el valor de "y".
Y bueno, me piden que encuentre los números y ya tengo dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas,
pero en esta ecuación ya tengo despejada a "x",
,por lo tanto voy a resolver este sistema
de ecuaciones y para resolver este sistema
de ecuaciones lo que voy a hacer es sustituir el valor de "x", aquí adentro, en esta otra ecuación,
cada vez que yo vea a "x" en esta
otra ecuación, voy a sustituir a esa misma
"x" por 25 más "2y", porque aquí me dice
que "x" es exactamente igual a 25 más "2y".
Y entonces me queda, 5 que multiplica a "x",
pero "x" es, 25 más "2y", perfecto...
5 que multiplica a 25 más "2y", esto porque
está multiplicando a "x" más "5y" es igual a 350.
Y date cuenta que aquí ya eliminé a la "x",
lo único que me queda es una ecuación que
solamente depende de "y", así que distribuyendo
me va a quedar 5 por 25, lo cual es 125, más
5 por "2y", lo cual es "10y" más "5y"
esto es igual a 350. Y ahora,
¿qué te parece si juntamos a estos dos de aquí?
¡Perfecto! "10y" más "5y" son "15y" muy bien.
Y ahora tengo 125 más "15y" esto es igual a 350.
¿Y de aquí cómo podemos despejar a "y"?
Lo primero que se me ocurre es que podemos
quitar a este 125, si yo resto 125 de ambos
lados de la ecuación, de este lado, del lado
izquierdo estos dos se van y solamente me
va a quedar que "15y" es igual a 350 menos 125.
"15y" es igual a...
¿y cuánto es 350 menos 125?
Esto es 225, ¡muy bien!
"15y" es igual a 225 y justo en este momento ya tenemos una ecuación muy parecida a la
ecuación que tengo aquí arriba, voy a dividir
todo entre 15 y me va a quedar que el valor
de "y" es igual a 225 entre 15, pero 225 entre 15 es 15.
Por lo tanto, ya obtuve el valor de "y", "y"
vale 15 y si sustituyo el valor "y" aquí,
voy a obtener el valor de "x". Como "y" vale 15, entonces en lugar de "y" voy a escribir 15.
Y me va a quedar 2 por 15, bueno, 2 por 15, esto de aquí es 30 y a 30 le voy a sumar 25, 30 más 25 es 55.
Y ya tengo los dos números, el primer número un número "x" es igual a 55, mientras que el otro número,
"y" es igual a 15.
Así que déjame borrar todo esto
para poder hacer el siguiente problema, el inciso c.
Y el inciso c, me dice que la suma de dos
enteros consecutivos es 35.
¿De qué números se trata?
Así que voy a decir, que "x" es el primer
entero de estos dos enteros consecutivos
y bueno, si "x" es el primero de ellos, entonces,
¿cómo podemos nombrar al otro de estos dos enteros?
Bueno, para no ponerle otro nombre, date cuenta que el consecutivo de "x" es "x" más 1,
por lo tanto "x" más 1 es el segundo de
estos enteros consecutivos.
Y dice que la suma de "x" más el entero consecutivo que le sigue a "x", es decir "x" más 1, esto es igual a 35.
Y de aquí, es muy fácil encontrar a "x",
porque "x" más "x" me da "2x" más 1 esto
es igual a 35, si de aquí resto 1 de ambos
lados de la ecuación, voy a llegar a que
"2x" es igual a 34 y ahora dividiendo todo
entre 2, me va a quedar que "x" es igual a
34 entre 2 lo cual es 17, "x" es igual a 17, "x" más 1 es igual a 18 y la suma de estos dos me da 35.
Así que ya está, aquí tengo el inciso c.
Y vamos a resolver el inciso d.
Que dice, Pedro es tres veces más viejo
que la edad que tenía hace 6 años.
¿Cuántos años tiene Pedro?
Así que voy a decir que la edad que tiene
Pedro actualmente va a ser "p".
"p" es igual a 3 veces más viejo que la edad
que tenía hace 6 años.
Por lo tanto 3 va a multiplicar a la edad
que tenía Pedro hace 6 años,
pero hace 6 años Pedro tenía 6 años menos, por lo tanto, a la edad que tiene actualmente Pedro le voy
a quitar 6 años para que así podamos representar
la edad que tenía Pedro hace 6 años.
Entonces "p" es igual a 3 que multiplica a
"p" menos 6, es decir, la edad de Pedro que
tenía hace 6 años, ¡y mira! de aquí ya
es muy fácil despejar a "p".
"p" es igual a 3 por "p", es "3p" y 3 por
-6, esto me da -18 y de aquí voy a despejar
a "p", si yo resto "3p" de ambos lados de
la ecuación, entonces del lado izquierdo
me va a quedar "-2p" "p" menos "3p" es lo
mismo que "-2p" y del lado derecho solamente
me va a quedar -18 y ahora si divido ambos
lados entre -2 me va a quedar que "p" es igual
a -18 entre -2, lo cual es 9.
Entonces Pedro solamente tiene 9 años,
está muy jovencito todavía ese Pedro.
Si la edad de Pedro actualmente son 9 años,
entonces "p" menos 6 son 3 años, esto quiere
decir que Pedro actualmente tiene el triple
de edad que tenía hace 6 años.
Entonces sí funciona.
¡Perfecto! me agradó mucho este problema
y vamos a hacer el siguiente.
Dice, problema 6, un reproductor MP3 decreció
en su precio un 20% del año pasado a este año.
Este año el precio del reproductor MP3
fue de 120 pesos.
¿Cuál fue su precio el año pasado?
Entonces vamos a decir que "p" es el precio
que tuvo el MP3 el año pasado.
Y bueno, para resolver este problema, entonces
quiero ver cómo le quitamos al precio del
año pasado el 20%, pero si decreció en un
20% esto quiere decir que al precio del año
pasado le voy a quitar .20, es decir, -0.20
por "p", aquí estoy representando el 20%
del precio del año pasado y le estoy quitando
esto al precio del año pasado y esto dice
que es igual a 120 pesos, que es lo que
cuesta actualmente.
Y ya tengo una ecuación muy fácil de resolver,
porque "p" menos "0.20p" es lo mismo que 1
menos .20, lo cual es 0.8 ó "0.80p", es decir,
me estoy quedando solamente con el 80% del valor
del precio que tenía el reproductor
MP3 el año pasado y esto es igual a 120.
Y ahora, si yo divido de ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 0.8, voy a dividir esto entre
0.8 ó 0.80 y aquí también entre 0.80, voy
a obtener así el valor de "p",
estos dos se van a cancelar y solamente tengo que hacer 120 entre 0.8.
Vamos a recordar cómo hacíamos una división
con decimales, 120 va a ser dividido por 0.8,
aquí voy a poner un punto y muchos 0 y hay
que recorrer el punto decimal, ¿te acuerdas?
Entonces vamos a recorrer el punto decimal
un lugar, un lugar hacia la derecha...
lo recorro un lugar hacia la derecha, aquí
lo voy a poner para que no se nos olvidé...
recuerda que es importante que los lugares
que recorramos el punto decimal afuera de
la división, va a ser los mismos lugares
que recorramos adentro de la división.
Y me queda 8 cabe una vez en 12, 1 por 8 es
8 y 12 menos 8 es 4, bajo ahora este 0 y 40
cabe 5 veces en 8, entonces 5 por 8 es 40,
¡perfecto! porque estoy ya es exacto, entonces
menos 40 me queda 0, 0, aquí voy a poner
un 0 y se siguen los 0.
Entonces el precio que tenía el reproductor
MP3 hace un año atrás era de 150 pesos
y lo padre de las matemáticas es que tú lo
puedes verificar.
Si tú le quitas el 20% a 150 pesos vamos
a llegar a 120 pesos.
Eso es lo padre del álgebra, que siempre
puedes verificar tu resultado...
Siempre puedes verificar que esté bien tu trabajo.